Our friends, Karen and Noah Vanna Clawson
have taken our show on the road,
cruising across the country,
shining a light on these amazing people
and places along the way.
And they recently made a pit stop in Albuquerque,
New Mexico, where they rattled up some new friends.
Take a look at this special edition of Barry Moore Tours.
(bright upbeat music)
Hey Drew,
we're in Albuquerque, New Mexico,
at the American International Rattlesnake Museum
and home of the world's largest collection
of rattlesnake species.
We gonna slither on in it, take a look.
(bright music)
So we're here with Bob Meyers, the founder and director
of the American International Rattlesnake Museum.
Bob. It's great to meet you.
Thanks for hosting us.
Good to meet you, dude.
So tell us about the museum.
When was it founded?
The Rattlesnake Museum was founded in 1990, 31 years ago.
So this is a huge tourist hotspot obviously.
Oh, we get in excess of 50,000 people every year.
How many rattlesnakes are there here?
Oh, we have 34 different species
and subspecies of rattlesnakes.
We have an albino here named, "Drew" of all things.
No.
Should we go take a look?
Come on.
All right, let's do it.
Thanks.
This is Drew, the Western Diamondback rattlesnake.
She happens to be a blonde.
She is Alpine.
Hi Drew.
Is she dangerous?
She's dangerous because of her eventual size
the length of those fangs,
the quantity of venom that she sprays.
What's the biggest thing people get wrong
about rattlesnakes?
Probably top on the list is the old wise tale
that you can tell the age of a rattlesnake
by counting the segments on the rattle.
The truth is they get a rattle segment
every time they shed their skin.
Let me introduce you to "AJ" Adam Jr.
He is an Eastern Diamondback rattlesnake,
the largest species of rattlesnake in the world,
Found on the Southeastern part of the country.
How long is this one?
"AJ" is six feet, two inches now.
Oh, my gosh.
It's beautiful.
Absolutely beautiful.
Thank you for letting us see him Bob.
Absolutely.
(audience applauding)
I really love that snake called "Drew."
I really do like that.
I know that I'm always seeming like so happy and optimistic
but I have a stinger.
We all do.
Nobody likes to be messed with.
And that's the funny thing,
is when you're always so optimistic,
people think you don't have like a spine
and a dark side.
(dramatic music)